Secretary Clinton welcome and we're here
at Swansea University where at the law
school with your name on it and you're
here to welcome the inaugural group of
Hillary Clinton global challenge
scholars so we're a long way from New
York or Washington how did this
relationship come about and it was the
most wonderful serendipity I received a
letter in the spring of 2017 asking if I
would be interested in an affiliation
with the University I am part Welsh
about 1/3 is my ancestry and there were
people here at the law school who had
followed some work that I had done for
many years and they asked if they could
name the law school for me I was
immensely honored I began talking with
them I came here this is my fourth visit
to Swansea and I just fell in love with
not only the area but also what the
University and the law school were doing
so I could not be happier and one of the
global challenges identified by this
scholarship with your name on it is
cyber security and you've talked a lot
about suspected Russian interference in
the 2016 US presidential election how
concerned are you about the next one I'm
very concerned and it's not just my
personal concern although that certainly
motivates me to try to learn as much as
I can it's what our own intelligence
officials under the current Trump
administration are also saying that
Russia never left our systems they are
involved in propaganda that they produce
and provide to Americans
disguised as though it were legitimate
news they are very much behind a lot of
what are called BOTS that flood the
internet and social media sites to carry
messages for or against candidates or
causes so I think that we haven't taken
the threat seriously and it's way past
time that we do and of course the UK is
about to head into a general election do
you have concerns around that well I
think there has been an accumulating
body of evidence that
there was Russian involvement in the
first brexit referendum and I think all
of us whether you are for or against the
current administration in the United
States for or against brexit should be
worried about an external power trying
to influence the votes of citizens and
as I said in London in a series of
interviews there is a government report
that should be released before the
election that does detail whatever the
Russian influence might have been
because I think voters have to wake up
and understand that it is an issue that
doesn't necessarily mean that they will
vote for or against somebody because of
it but don't we want to be informed
citizens before we cast votes I think we
do and on the subject of the election
Facebook has refused to ban political
advertising unlike Twitter so who and
your views got it right twitter has it
right because Facebook has refused to
take down blatantly false advertising
and what Twitter decided was look we
can't be the judge of it that would be
you know too much of a burden on us so
let's just ban political advertising I
think that is the right decision I'm
very disappointed in Facebook in the
United States slightly more than half of
the people get their news from Facebook
and in many instances it's the only
source of news so if they are being
bombarded with absolutely false attacks
on a political candidate how are they to
know any different because the
traditional media the broadcast and
cable networks refused to run the very
same ad that Facebook decided to run I
think that's another issue that we're
going to have to address in both of our
countries
Facebook says it's about free expression
and that all posts by politicians would
be treated as newsworthy content that
should be seen and heard well they are
misinterpreting as many experts have
told them what free expression means you
know free expression doesn't mean
yelling fire in a crowded theater free
expression does not mean knowingly
permitting false information on public
channels that has always been the the
rules that we have lived by in the
United States and you know Facebook is
basically saying you know we're totally
hands
we don't care what is said yet the
responsibility for conveying that
information has to rest somewhere and I
think if they will not exercise any
self-discipline there will have to be
regulatory and legal changes you've been
in UK promoting the book that you've
written with your daughter Chelsea the
book of gutsy women which celebrates
resilient and courageous women that we
should aspire to but at the moment for
politicians at least it's a time of
unprecedented abuse so many have come
out and talked about how they've had
threats made against them he'd have to
be really gutsy to want to be a
politician at the moment wouldn't you
unfortunately yes
I was really shocked when I was in
London talking with and and hearing from
former and current members of the House
of Commons the House of Lords about the
threats that they receive online the
hate that is directed toward them
unfortunately and sadly we can remember
the politically motivated murder of Joe
Cox a parliamentarian and a lot of women
are saying I want to serve but I can't
take the risk not just to themselves but
to their families because in some of the
instances those who were hurling those
threats were mentioning their children
it's a terrible loss for our democracy
we need to be encouraging people to run
for office and to serve and we need a
diversity of voices because that's what
a parliament should represent so I think
that the government law enforcement
everyone needs to step up and say that
they're not going to permit these kinds
of you know threats and they're
certainly going to provide security to
everyone who does run and serve I'm
talking of running for office you've
been asked a number of times about
whether you're considering running again
you haven't said yes but you have said
never say never so what is it that
you're weighing up here what's under
consideration what would swing it well I
never really seriously considered it but
I have been the subject of a number of
people urging me to do so I have no
plans to do it I
that there are many roles to play many
positions to champion that I'm going to
continue to pursue and I feel like it's
not just about individual candidates
anymore it's about our whole system of
democracy that is under attack and I
think we need a lot more voices saying
ok regardless of party regardless of
position we've got to protect the
fundamentals of democracy you know the
rule of law respect for our institutions
civil discourse minority rights these
are all things along with freedom of
speech and assembly and the like that
have built our two democracies you're
the oldest Parliament in the world we
have been at it for you know somewhat
over 200 years but now I think we face
threats from within and without and I am
going to continue to be very vocal about
that Anu and your daughter Chelsea are
celebrating women who are courageous and
resilient but are also changing the
world for others so would you like
Chelsea to run for president oh I don't
know I want her to do what makes her
happy and gives her purpose in life
she's an incredible spokesperson and
advocate on all kinds of causes and I
think she's very very gutsy herself but
any future political decision she
certainly is not thinking about it now
would have to be you know considered and
made by her but you think she could do
it in future I think she could do
anything I think she is an
extraordinarily talented person well
you've been here in the UK the first
public impeachment hearings have been
going on in the United States President
Trump has said he's been too busy to
watch have you been watching I've caught
excerpts of it because I had that time
differences made it a little bit
difficult because of my obligations and
I've read all of the reporting and
analysis and I think that the testimony
that was already presented is
devastating these are not partisan
people at all they are public servants
two very experienced diplomats who were
just reciting the facts as they knew
them what they had seen what they had
heard and why it mattered
look I have a lot of experience in
practicing law evaluating facts
understanding how it applies and I was
actually a young lawyer on the
impeachment staff that investigated
Richard Nixon when he was being
considered for impeachment and I think
that the Democrats in Congress who are
running this process have been very
careful vigilant about not getting ahead
of themselves following the facts where
they lead and I will not be at all
surprised if the house decides to
impeach Donald Trump so you think it
could well happen
I do because I know from the experience
with Richard Nixon the abuse of power
the obstruction of justice the contempt
of Congress that were the allegations
against him we've already seen evidence
of it's pretty simple you know the our
Constitution talks about not only high
crimes and misdemeanors but also bribery
and bribery doesn't have to just be
person-to-person it can be nation to
nation in the sense that a president
would abuse his office to try to coerce
the president of another country in
desperate need of military assistance to
protect his country against Russian
aggression that he would not get that
assistance unless he manufactured
information that could be used against
the president's political opponents that
is exactly the kind of abuse that the
people who wrote our Constitution were
most worried about I want to ask you
about a case here in Britain of harried
an young man 19 year old man he was
killed in a road accident and the
suspect who's the wife of a US diplomat
working here in the UK claims a
traumatic immunity and went back to the
United States he was secretary of state
for a number of years does that sound
like a proper use of diplomatic immunity
to you I first of all just want to
express you know my condolences to his
family I can't even imagine the pain and
suffering that they are feeling
the loss of their son and I also regret
the incident at the White House which
seemed quite clumsy and and and
heavy-handed that they were subjected to
there is a proper approach to
determining what is the appropriate use
of diplomatic immunity I think that
should certainly be looked into and our
government should be cooperating with
the authorities here in the UK to
determine whether or not it was there
are clear lines that govern diplomatic
immunity sometimes it causes
consternation we've had that in our
country when something happened and and
a diplomat was able to leave but then
there are grey areas so I would hope
that experienced heads are trying to
figure out the appropriate response and
do you think that the suspects unsecure
should be sent back to the UK to face
justice I can't jump to that conclusion
you know there's something called the
Vienna Convention there's all kinds of
precedent about when diplomatic immunity
applies when it doesn't that's why there
should be this very thoughtful inquiry
that our country and yours undertakes to
determine was it or was it not
appropriate and what should be the
follow-on remedies and actions depending
upon the finding and you'll be heading
back to the United States soon will you
be watching the general election unfold
in the UK closely very closely you know
I do not in any way take a stand in the
politics of the UK that is up to the
people here but it really matters
how the UK moves forward into the future
because you know you really are our very
special partner and when you believe as
I do that our democracies are under
attack from both forces within and
forces without we've got to get our acts
together and making a decision whatever
the outcome going forward or not remain
or not at least we've got to get some
closure so that decisions can be made
there is so much that we have to contend
with in the world today and there are so
many opportunities that speaking from my
own country we are letting go on address
you know we're not dealing with
technology and some of the questions
that it raises including the very real
set of issues around artificial
intelligence we are certainly not
dealing with climate change in the sense
of the emergency that it presents we're
not dealing with the refugee crisis you
know we have tens and hundreds of
thousands of people at our border Europe
has been you know really deluge by
desperate people what are we gonna do
about that how do we help people stay
where they are and have some kind of
future there so that they don't risk
their lives and also cause all kinds of
issues for us and the list goes on how
do we get the economy to work so that
middle class people feel like they're
getting a fair shake again and people
feel like you know when you say you can
make what you will of yourself you know
it's true it's not just a slogan so
right now I think in your country and
mine we are all bollixed up in politics
out of the worst kind we are you know
not coming together not finding common
ground not making good decisions
so elections should be always about the
future not looking backwards and and I
hope that you know within a year's time
both of our countries will be back on
the right track together and just to
revisit impeachment just for a moment
the impeachment hearings President Trump
calls it a witch-hunt President Trump
seems not to either understand or care
about the law rule of law or our
Constitution and he denies reality on a
daily basis it's how he communicates
what he wants people to believe and so
when evidence comes forward as it did
from very credible sources that he was
using his office to withhold military
aid that had been voted for by our
Congress in order to force a country's
resident to do his bidding that's not a
witch hunt those are troubling facts
that need to be investigated that's what
is going on now and sadly he seems to
only care about his own future not the
future of our democracy or our country
and it's exactly the kind of set of
facts that our founders who wrote our
constitution we're worried about you
know we have elections and they could
have been sitting around at the
Constitutional Convention saying okay so
we get a you know a bad character in and
he's doing things that are undermining
our national security and you know
enriching himself but we'll wait to the
next election but they didn't say that
they said you know when it's severe
enough we're gonna put a provision in
our Constitution that can be triggered
by an equal but separate branch the
Congress to determine whether a
president has defied the Constitution
defied the laws that's what the
impeachment process is for the way it
works is that the House of
Representatives considers the evidence
and then it's like an indictment or a
charge in a in a case and they decide
are there articles of impeachment to be
drawn or not then it goes to the Senate
for a trial and the Senate then actually
weighs the evidence they act in effect
as jurors it's not a witch hunt it's a
it's a it's a triggering of our
Constitution I don't know anyone who's
happy about it and even people like
myself who are very worried about his
presidency and how he's conducted
himself
I don't celebrate the fact that he has
triggered this impeachment investigation
it's not good for our country it's a
terrible remedy that is being deployed
but it's based on facts and it's based
on the law and it's based on the
Constitution so as many times as he said
it's a you know witch hunt he's wrong
and at some point he should accept
responsibility for what he said and what
he did